[Müzik]
Merhabalar ben Kübra bugün sizlerin
karşısında bir milli sporcu olarak
duruyorum sizlere 90 saniyelik
performansım için 15 yıldır tutkunun
peşinden nasıl gittiğimi ve bu yolda
giderken dış seslere karşı nasıl sağır
olduğumu anlatmak istiyorum
insan Kars'ta çıkan fırsatları
değerlendirmek ister hayatta bana sporla
tanışmam için çok güzel bir fırsat sundu
babam boksan treni amcamda tekvando
antrenörüydü Ben de bu aileden sporcu
çıkmak zorundaydım başka bir fırsatım
yoktu
Bu arada havaya atan her tekmine karete
olmadığını söylemek istiyorum ben
Tekvando branşında Milli sporcuyum size
şimdi sporumu tanıtmak istiyorum
tekvando çıplak el ve ayakla yapılan
savunma sporudur ve bu spor kendi içinde
4 kategoriden oluşmaktadır
birincisi kıyirogi kıyır Ogi 2 sporcunun
karşılıklı puan almaya dayalı dövüşü
yani mücadelesidir ikincisi kiyopca
belirli tekvando hareketleri yapılan
tahta kırışları üçüncüsü yakın dövüş
sanatı ve dördüncüsü benim yarıştığım
kategori pumse kategorisi nedir
tekvandonun temel tekniklerini belirli
bir sıraya koyarak onun korografik
şeklindeki sunumudur mesela
bunun müzikli daha ekstrem hali
diyebiliriz
gene size kendimin en başında götüreyim
Ben 12 yaşında babam ve amcamın
işlettiği spor salonunda tekvandoya
başladım ilk antrenmanda dedim ki işte
bu benim sporum veya antrenmanlara Çok
keyifli gidip gelmeye başladım Hiç
kaçırmadan her şeyden fedakarlık edip
bir şeylerin peşinden giderseniz o ilk
diş sesler gelmeye başlıyor yolda benim
antrenmanlara gidip gelirken gören
teyzeler kolu komşular akrabalar kız
kısmı spor mu yapar
karateci ne yapacaksın erkek sporunda
Vallahi bak bacakların yamulur seni de
alan olmaz demeye başladılar
tabi o zamanlar çok fazla kadın sporcu
yoktu Ben de böyle karate değil tekvando
Hem ne alaka kızlar da yapar deyip
antrenmanlarına devam ettim ben devam
ettikçe hareketleri yapmaya başladıkça
bu sefer bana kız gibi yapmak kız gibi
yapıyorsun demeye başladılar sanki kız
gibi yapmanın beceriksiz aciz bir şeymiş
gibi lanse ediliyordu
yıllar böyle hızlıca geçti bir gün
antrenörüm Özlem hocamla birlikte
muhabbet ediyoruz bana Kübra hedefin ne
dedi Ben de hocam İstanbul şampiyonu
olmak istiyorum dedim Hayır Kübra dedi
hedefini yüksek tuttu Sen dünya
şampiyonu olacaksın dedi Ben de hocam
nasıl olayım dünyayı hayatta olamam çok
zor bir şey diyordum Hayır Kübra bak
dedi grupla 5 saat antrenman yaptım
Herkese aynı şeyi gösterdim aynı şeyi
verdim herkes antreman ilk saatlerinde
dökülmeye Başladı salmaya Başladı
yapmamaya başladı Sense antrenman ilk
saatinden son saatine aynı istek ve Arzu
ile antrenmanlarına devam ediyordum dedi
O yüzden sende Işık görüyorum Sen dünya
şampiyonu olacaksın dedi
ben Doğan heyecanlandım o an başarıyı
açtık Beni motive etti hemen eve gittim
şampiyon sporcuları videolarını falan
izlemeye başladım ilk 17 yaşında milli
takıma girdim
o yıl Avrupa Şampiyonası vardı ilk defa
yabancı ülkeye gidip ülkemi temsil
edecektim aşırı heyecanlıydım Hatta ilk
elimin ayağımı titrediğini o yarışmada
hissetmiştim
Çok şükür o yarışmada Gençler Avrupa
şampiyonu oldum
o yıl aynı zamanda da 2013 Endonezya'da
yapılan Dünya Şampiyonası vardı ama o
yarışmadan hatırladım tek şey kendime
aşırı derecede yetersiz hissetmeme oldu
dünya şampiyonaları bambaşka bir yerde
çok zordu
o yıl ülkeme Ellerim Bomboş geri döndüm
o yarışmada Hemen döner dönmez elime bir
defter aldı eksilerimi artılarımı yazdım
kendime plan program hazırladım
rakiplerimin mutabakalarını izleyip Ben
onlardan daha iyi nasıl yapabilirim
deyip analiz ediyordum programın dışına
asla çıkmadım Çünkü 2014 yılındaki
Meksika'da yapılacak olan dünya
şampiyonasını hazırlanıyordum hedefim
orada Tabii derece yapmaktı
O yılda ilk büyükler yarışmam olacaktı
büyükler kategorisi de Kurtlar Sofrası
gibi hepsi tecrübeli rakiplerim
O yılda Türkiye'de derece yapıp milli
takıma girmeye hak kazandım ve kamplarda
antrenmanlara giderken o kadar hevesle
gidiyorum ki fakat dış sesler hayatına
yine girmeye başladı Bir antrenör Mobile
uygulamaya başladı
aşırı Yeteneksizsin Bu nasıl bir tekme
nasıl geldin sen buraya demeye başladı
hoca Ben de milli takım antrenörleri
seçtik diyordum ama bir antrenörüm
bunları demesi beni gerçekten kötü
olduğunu inandırmaya başlamıştı Sırf o
antrenör Bana bir daha ki antrenmanda
laf söz söylemesin diye her gece herkes
uyurken ben kalkıp tekme çalışmaları
yapıyordum
daha sonra yarışma günü geldi ve ben o
yarışmada dünya ikincisi oldum
çok mutluydum hemen otele geçtim bir
baktım dünya Tekvando Federasyonu benim
Uçan tekmemi kapak fotoğrafı yapmıştı
Hani o Hiçbir şey yapamaz dedikleri
kızım fotoğrafı kapak fotoğrafı olmuştu
Aslında bu da tatlı hissettilere atılan
bir tekneydi fotoğraf
teşekkür ederim
o yıl benim dönüm noktam olmuştu bütün
dünya şampiyonasındaki arkadaşlarım
benimle fotoğraf çekiliyordu Sanki ben
dünya şampiyonu olmuşum gibi benim
performansımı ödüyorlardı böyle böyle
yeni bilgilerim oldu
kazandığı maçlarım oldu bana 2013
yılında Dünya şampiyonu olduğum zaman
şansa bol oldu demişlerdi Şimdi ikinci
kez 2015 yılında Sırbistan'da yapılan
Avrupa şampiyonasına katıldım burada hem
Ferdi kategorisi hem de çiftler
kategorisinde yarıştım verdiği
kategorisini Avrupa şampiyonu olmuştum
fakat şampiyonluğa sadece bir saatliğine
yaşadım Neden Çünkü ikinci olan Rakibim
de aynı puanı aldım
sistem beni birinciliğe yerleştirirken
hakemlerin Rakibim 1 olacağını istedi ve
onu birinci yaptı ben o yarışmada İkinci
oldum Hayat size tutkunuzun peşinden
giderken ufak oyunlar oynuyor aynı
yarışmada Emirhan ile beraber çiftler
kategorisinde yarıştık ve o yarışmada da
Avrupa şampiyonu oldu
dış sesler yine yükselmeye başladı bu
sefer takım arkadaşın Emirhan sayesinde
şampiyon olduğunu demeye başladılar
Halbuki o yarışmada ben de derece yaptım
ben de şampiyon olmuştu Ama herkes onu
görmezlikten geliyordu Ben de sağır
olmayı tercih ediyordum bu durumda
mesela yere düşüyorum antrenmanda
diyorum acaba ben çok mu yeteneksizim ya
sonra kalkıyorum tekrardan hedeflerimi
hayallerimi düşünüyorum tekrardan
deniyorum gece mesela Yatıyorum Her Yer
Karanlık aklıma bir hareket takılıyor
kalkıyorum ona Gece karanlıkta o
hareketi yapıyorum hırsız yapım var
çünkü
daha sonra 2016 dünya şampiyonası vardı
Peru'da ve ben o yıl üniversiteye
antrenmanlarından dolayı gitmedim
hedefim dünya şampiyonu olmaktı
çok yoğun antrenman esnasında ben
maalesef düşüp ayak tendon bağlarımı
kopardım ve bu sakatlık beni tam 6 ay
geriye attı hemen emirhan'la Ne
yapabileceğimizi düşündük farklı bir
antrenman metoduna geçtik o yıl 5
buçukta kalkıyorduk ve toplam günde 6
saate kadar antrenman yapıyorduk
o kadar çok çalışıyordu ki içimizde
hedefe kitlenmiştik daha sonra yarışma
günü geldi
İkimiz de o kadar heyecanlandık ki
heyecandan hareketleri unutmamıza rağmen
o kadar çok çalışmışız ki vücudumuz
müziğin akışına kendiliğinden uyuyordu o
an yarışma alanı en son biz çıkmıştık
Bizim sonucumuz Tüm ülkeleri
etkileyecekti
o an benim yarışma bitti tek duyduğum
şey kalp seslerimde aşırı heyecanlıydık
yarışma bitti puanlar açıklandı bir
baktık dünya şampiyonu olmuşuz
o kadar mutluyuz inanamıyoruz arkada
Türk milli takımımızın Türkiye Türkiye
diye Sevinç çığlıkları bütün ülkeler
bize alkışlıyor Herkes performansımıza
çok iyi olduğunu söylüyordu
o an İstiklal Marşı'nı okumaya çıkacağız
kürsiye Çıktım ben İstiklal Marşı'nı
okurken gözümün önünden yaşadıklarım
şerit gibi geçti
çalışmalarımız sakatlıklarımız kızlar
yapamazdı Bu spor erkek spor idi dedim
ki bu kız her şeyi yapar dış sesler bir
anlığına kesildi o gün Başımı yastığa
huzurla koydum Normalde 55 kiloyum ama
ben kendimi Tüyü kadar hafif hissettim
sana üzerinden büyük büyük kalkmıştı
hemen elime telefonu aldım Instagram'a
girdim biyografi kısmına dünya şampiyonu
yazacağım titrediğini hatırlıyorum o an
yazdım sana Allah'a şükür dünya
şampiyonu olduk deyip fotoğrafı
paylaştım ve yaptım Peru'da geceyken
Türkiye'de gündüzü saat farkı vardı
Sabah bir kalktım benim bin takipçili
hesabım her yenilediğimde 20.000 40.000
50.000 60 70 diye gidiyordu bütün
sayfalar beni paylaşıyordu Normalde
bireysel sporlarda çok fazla böyle
Paylaşılmaz
ben şöyle hayal ediyorum dünya şampiyonu
oldum ülkem benimle gurur duyacaktır
İstiklal Marşı'mızı tüm dünyayı
dinlettik
daha tutkunun peşinden giderken bir de
ona şampiyonlukla taçlandırmışken dış
sesler yine bir alnına yükseldi
yorumlara baktım ne göreyim Meğer benim
başarımı değil başörtümü konuşuyorlarmış
dünya şampiyonu olmuşum da ne olmuş
ayaklarım görünüyormuş tahrik
ediciymişim başımı Kapatmışım ayağımı
kaldırıyormuşum Gerçekten bu tarz karı
yorumlar vardı
bu Yorumları gören milli takım
antrenörlerimiz beni ve dünya şampiyonu
olan Elif arkadaşımıza yanımıza çağırdı
Elif'i sarı saçlı kırmızı olduğu için
ona farklı yorumlar geliyordu Ben
başörtülü olduğum için bana farklı
yorumlar geliyordu dış sesler Ya bunlar
başarıları değil konuşulmaması
gerekenleri konuşuyor
daha sonra dış seslerin taraf
değiştirdiğini gördüm kimi dedi ki Helal
olsun ya ülkemizin gururu herkes her
şekilde her şeyi başarabileceğini
göstermiş oldu dedi Kimi de bu ne ya
Oğuzhan olur olmazsa ne olur bana ne
deyip geçiştirdi bırakın dış sesler
kendi aralarında tartışmaya devam etsin
bir söz vardır bir işi tutkuyla
yapıyorsanız artık o sizin tutkunuz
olmaktan çıkıyor Artık örnek bir kişi
oluyorsunuz Senden sonra geleceklerin
örnek alacağı artık her fırsatta
ailelere kız çocuklarına spor yapmasının
ne kadar önemli olduğunu anlattım artık
aileler şöyle demeye başladı bak kızım
sen de spor yap çok çalış Kübra ablan
gibi ol demeye başladı bu sayede de
birçok kız çocuğuna Işık olmuş oldum
o yılın kadın sporcu seçilerek de
herkesin her şekilde başarabileceğini
göstermiş oldu
yıl 2017
Yunanistan'da yapılan Avrupa
şampiyonasında 3 kez Avrupa şampiyonu
oldu
her başarı sizin tutkunuzu körükler
2018'deki dünya şampiyonluğuna
hazırlığın başladı
şimdiki hedefim ikinci kez dünya
şampiyonu hedefimi korumaktı o kadar çok
çalışıyoruz ki fakat biz yarışma kamp
tarihi Beklerken milli takım kamp tarihi
Beklerken bir baktık milli takımımızın o
gün yarışmaya katılmama kararını Duyduk
ve hiçbir şekilde açıklama dahi
yapmadılar neden katılmadı hakkında
bazen Siz çok çalışsanıza şartlar başarı
için uygun olmuyor Hemen döner dönmez
2020 dünya şampiyonasına çalışmalarımız
başladı
ve maalesef O yılda Corona çıktı yine
dünya şampiyonasına gidemedik
durmak yok tutkumuz için çalışmaya devam
yıl 2021 Türkiye'de şampiyon olup
Portekiz'de yapılacak olan Avrupa
şampiyonasına gitmeye hak kazandık yine
sabah akşam gece gündüz bizi
antrenmanlarımızı yaparken dış sesler
yine yükselmeye başladı
sizi zaten maçlara götürmüyorlar sizi
önem vermiyorlar sizin atamanızı bile
yapmıyorlar Siz niye hala çalışıyorsunuz
biz bunları duyarken hala çalışmaya
devam ediyoruz
fakat yine biz kamp tarihi Beklerken bir
baktık yarışmanın kayıt tarihi gelmiş
hala hiçbir şeyde ses seda yok hemen
yetkili kişileri aradık yarın haber
vereceğiz yarın haber vereceğiz
gidileceğini deyip bize ertelediler
acaba bu sefer de sesler haklı mıydılar
da sesler sizi uğraşırsanız sizi
kandırmak için elinden geleni yapar
gidemezsiniz uçak yok derler olmaz
derler derde derler ama biz tutkumuzu
paylaştığımız kişilerden güç aldık bizim
sesimizi de Kenan Sofuoğlu duydu ve bizi
2021 Avrupa şampiyonasına gitmemize
yardımcı oldu
o yarışmayı çok farklı motivasyonla
gittik Çünkü çok geç kalmıştık yarışmaya
gittik uçaktan indik Ertesi sabah saat
6'da yarıştık ve çok şükür o yarışmada
da 4 kez Avrupa şampiyonu olup İstiklal
Marşı'mızı tüm ülkeleri dinletmiş olduk
teşekkür ederim
hemen
o motivasyonla gelir gelmez Kore'de
yapılacak olan 2022 Kore'de yapılacak
olan dünya şampiyonuna hazırlığımız
başladı İnşallah bu sefer gidecektik
Çünkü Türkiye en son 6 yıl önce dünya
şampiyonasına katılmıştı
bu sefer gitme umuduyla daha da çok
çalışıyoruz Çünkü dediğim gibi ikinci
kez dünya şampiyonu olma hedefimiz var
fakat sonuç yine hüsran yine gidilmeme
kararı aldım
dış sesler yine iş başında bu sefer
kendi hissesini duy Çünkü sana doğru
yolu gösterecektir en son dünya
şampiyonu olduğumda 20 yaşındayım Şu an
26 yaşındayım ama hala dünya şampiyonası
gitme umuduyla antrenmanlarıma devam
ediyorum Sizce Buna ne denir enayilik mi
tutku mu yoksa kendimiz olan saygımız mı
bayrak sevdasını Aslında hepsi Çünkü
Tutku sizin her şeyinizdir teşekkür
ederim